so just wanting to give you an update on  the matera water issue we've got leak  detection services here trying to locate  the any potential significant lakes but  in the meantime we've started emergency  pumping from the matera River and work  out a straight well the water is mixed  with the water coming from the fluid and  we we do expect some taste and odor  issues in the network are just trying to  de-stress but it still is fully treated  for our treatment plan so perfectly safe  to drink but appreciate that sometimes  we might be tasting otoshi  so to help out with that we and the  process of organizing a water cap to  come from out of the district and  that'll be back down at the mature  service center something you can come  down po-po your containers basis is this  board up for drinking purposes only  everything else can't they just use the  water additive